rect de kiev tetyana hoggar kova bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
journaliste responsable du département
international à l'ukraine crisis media
center vous vous trouvez donc à kiev est
ce que vous pouvez nous dire pour le
moment quelle est la situation à kiev
quelles sont les informations dont vous
disposez un beau jour effectivement je
me trouve quille n 1 dans une banlieue
on va le dire dans une ville sa télé de
kiev à dix kilomètres de kiev
effectivement les nuits étaient très
perturbés et puisque à peu à partir de 5
heures du matin nous avons commencé à
entendre des des sons très bizarre qu'on
a investi fier dans un premier temps
qu'on des bombardements aux 3 4 5 peut
être et c'est à ce moment là qu on avait
écouté et vous gardez en fait là à
l'adresse de volume est possible
d'annoncer clairement la guerre donc
depuis ce depuis là ce matin la
situation est calme en tout cas dans vos
quartiers on reçoit des informations que
dans certains quartiers de qui aiment
pas de centrales on entendait des bd
sont des bombardements du missile a
encore à cette heure de matin mais
finalement aujourd'hui bas à ce moment
si on pense plutôt à des attaques comme
abou bien eu raison de dire gulliver
attaques contre les uns les autres les
objets militaires on s'est cabré varie
dans une ville satellite de guy roux on
la vit dans un jardin d'enfants
dans une cité militaire il y avait il ya
des gens à mort et quelques blessés donc
c'est là selon la formation qu'on a
reçues on a reçu aussi le coin signe du
du maire de kiev klitschko que de rester
sur place et que rester en sécurité les
écoles sont fermées on a bien reçu les
informations que les écoles les crèches
tout est fermé par contre on voit bien
sur les google maps qu' il ya des
bouchons pour sortir de la ville on a vu
quelques trafics ici mais la plupart des
voitures si vous voulez qu'ils sont
garés ou que je peux voir par ma fenêtre
au reste sur place mais ça n'empêche
qu'une partie des gens et c'est de
partir de quitter la ville puisque c'est
vrai que ça fait vraiment peur les
bombarder mots les sons sont très
menaçants ces sondes et ne jamais
entendu la vie des gens de qui elles ne
sont pas habituées du tout à cela et
donc voilà c'est très c'est très
dramatique fait c'est très grave c'est
impensable betiana hoggar kova bonjour
comment l'ukraine prépare sa riposte
ce matin on le sait depuis plusieurs
jours des habitants de kiev notamment
aller s'entraîner en périphérie de la
capitale pour s'entraîner aux techniques
militaires de base pour pouvoir se
défendre aujourd'hui quel est l'état
d'esprit des ukrainiens et ce qu'il
compte sur eux mêmes ou est ce qu'ils
attendent des réponses fortes de la
communauté internationale
écoutez bien sûr les esprits c'est que
je peux voir dans mon entourage dans les
réseaux sociaux d'aller dans le cercle
d'amis je vois que l'esprit et seront
que les gens qui sont qui sont d'alarmé
ils font ce qu'ils chose qu'il doit
faire
les gens qui sont dans la défense
territoriale c'est à dire les unités
soit exprès pour défendre les
territoires ils ont leur coin signe donc
qu'ils vont faire ce qu'il doit faire
après les populations civiles restent
essayé de suivre les consignes de
domaines on va pas créer de panique
donc et bien sûr le cren manquements
avaient été annoncées par zielinski et
l'ukraine pour qu'il faut faire
confiance à notre armée bien si même si
on sait que l'armée russe des parce
qu'il tient des forces aériennes par
exemple que que le crâne ne possède pas
mais en même temps on compte beaucoup
sur la solidarité européenne et euro
atlantique c'est vrai que sans alliés
sans partenaire ce serait extraordinaire
pour le pour le crains que de mener à 47
guerres en même temps on est convaincu
il ya quand même le sentiment que cette
guerre il est un dieu jusqu'au dernier
moment on savait que c'était possible
mais on espérait que parce que c'est un
acte de folie en fait c'est sait ça
relève de l'impensable on est quand même
convaincu que ce sera la dernière guerre
de vladimir poutine que il va y périrent
son régime en tout cas tout aussi bien
que voilà tout aussi bien donc ça c'est
une signe de faiblesse en fait puisque
cette guerre c'est une suite dé la
compréhension très clair de la part de
poutine qu'elle n'a pas réussi à
conquérir le crains politiquement
diplomatiquement avec les accords de
minsk il a voilà donc ce qui leur reste
à faire parce que c'est le cren ccct
l'avoir d'année gauche marc mais ceux
qui verraient c'est justement les
emplois de force absolument injustifié
ce sont deux dernières métaux c'est son
dernier recueil ici il n'a pas de succès
et donc on espère toujours avec l'aide
de nos partenaires haut en bas on va
faire face à cette menace en vélo voilà
il va pas arriver à ses fins donc ça
sera la dernière guerre de rené merkt
chine est ce que vous diriez que
l'ukraine ait est divisée aujourd'hui ou
est ce qu'elle est unie face à cette
invasion qui est en train de se produire
il n'y a pas de raison d'être des visées
et il ya tout le monde est concerné très
content qu'on partait trop russe
non il ya juste et viable selon les
sondages sociologique on a l'habitude de
cité il ya très peu donc il ya très peu
de gens qui soutiennent déjà l'amitié
avec la russie mais les actions de
poutine donc on peut aller les soutenir
donc je crois que poutine a encore perdu
cette nuit-là faire du dramatiquement
hélas aucune donc il ya aucune encore
moyen que de 2 voilà d'euros gagnés
conservative des gens que tu bombarde
n'est ce pas donc c'est logique elle a
déjà perdu ou l'ukraine politiquement à
2014 en annexant la crimée en occupant
d'une basse donc on a bien vu dans les
sondages que les les voilà les
sympathies les sympathisants craignant
qu'ils allaient vers l'irb la nation
russe v.poutine cetera ils ont
dramatiquement diminué pendant ses huit
ans aujourd'hui donc des soutiens pas de
sondages de soma temps mais je suis
convaincu que personne ne veut être
personne n'aime pas être bombardées par
son neveu n'aime pas être voilà être
agressés de cette manière ils se sont
pas s'ils sont pas des métaux qui on
peut employer dans le monde civilisé
donc quand ils montrent très clairement
qu'ils de l'autre côté de la
civilisation qu'il est capable à tous on
parle aussi de
son état mental qui peut être très grave
puisque ça fait deux ans qu'il est dans
son bon coeur qu'elle est quand même
très désolé parce que les ex-anpe hors
du commun d'un virus issa sa paranoïa
avec développer donc c'est un état
d'esprit qui justifie en quelque sorte
parce que c'est sa volée de l'impensable
jamais de ma vie je n'aurais pas imaginé
ces images là qu'on a vu aujourd'hui
jamais des lobbys mes parents les gens
qui ont vécu la plage majorité de leur
vie dans l'union celui ci pose pas
imaginer voir la russie agressé mais le
tarn où l ukraine à grande échelle donc
savoleyres de l'impensable donc c'est or
ça dépasse tout le possible donc
aujourd'hui il faut s'unir messieurs
zelensky président zine ce qui a fait
appel aux partenaires occidentaux de
faire alliance anti poutine on est
convaincu que c'est un sur les moyens
que d' arrêter cette folie cette guerre
au coeur de l'europe cette guerre qui ne
va apporter de bonheur niel craignent à
tous les pim puis voisons et tout le
pays membres de l'union européenne
puisque ça concerne tout le monde au
loonie donc autant de rester solidaire
et unie face à cette menace
qui est très grave
merci beaucoup tetyana hoggar kova
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste responsable du
département international